[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
make way for uh mark sanchez former nfl
quarterback usc qb a fox nfl analyst
he's going to be uh covering the jags
and rams coming up on sunday mark joins
us good morning mark how are you
good morning what's going on guys uh
let's see six two and a quarter and uh
give me 235 at the moment
did you lie about height or weight when
you were in college or the nfl
uh
in high school yes
i think i put like six three or
something but after that i just kept six
two and after the combine it's like all
right everybody measured me
can't lie about that anymore what do you
what do you remember about the combine
oh
so i
i dislocated my kneecap going into my
last season at usc
like the second practice
so i sat out most of training camp came
back for the opener against virginia on
the road and i had to wear this brace
that like basically kept my kneecap in
place while i'm running around and stuff
because once it dislocates it's prone to
do it again
so at the combine
everybody's got to check it out
for the couple days of the medical exams
and so everybody's just cranking on this
knee
and
this thing blew up like a basketball
in the hotel room and i was like icing
this thing
all night just to get to the next day so
i could go out run my 40 and do all the
physical stuff
it was a disaster but every doctor from
every single team was like oh this is
the knee how does this feel you know and
they're just like
cranking on it i'm like dude and you
can't say anything
you know
and by the end of the day this thing was
just
so big and so annoying
uh but i ended up getting it fixed after
my uh after my rookie season it popped
out again my rookie year
so yeah the combine was a disaster i was
talking to matt liner yesterday and he
talked about it i heard him i heard him
yeah he talked about you two taking
ballroom dancing together
now he had already graduated so
he needed two credit you were a freshman
taking ballroom dan was that your major
[Laughter]
no i think uh without the kneecap issue
i might have been a professional dancer
oh okay
dancing with the stars okay matt was
like i can't he's like i can't remember
any dances well our teacher was jesus
everybody called him jay
and uh he was a trip
but
the
you know i'm not gonna name any names
but the gal that matt was seeing in
school her friend became my partner was
my dance partner
and she was like she was a total babe
and you know had a mini crush on her and
we danced and on tuesday nights and had
our little thing it was cool i thought
it was awesome i like how matt you know
didn't i said man a great place to meet
women if you're in college taking
ballroom dancing oh yeah he dodged that
thing like the play holy cow that was
funny
um he said that he was hearing matt
campbell at iowa state was the guy that
usc was kind of zeroing in on before
they got lincoln riley who were you
hearing us he was going to hire i was
hearing that i was hearing that um
sunday
you know right before all this went down
i thought that was going to happen i
thought the fickle thing was going to
happen potentially because of uh
his connection with mike bone apparently
um he was a former id there and they
were together or something so which you
know those guys would have been
those guys would be great but i think
this one was just such a big splash
and so exciting offensively and so
exciting for recruiting
you know and i don't know
we could have gotten anybody better i
was just as excited as matt
but what has happened since since pete
carroll left like what
what
what left with uh when pete left
the recruits left california i mean
think about it the kids started it the
kid who was starting at georgia
was for modern day for a little bit and
then they you know switch quarterbacks
or whatever but jt daniels was from
modern day yeah and he's in athens
georgia
the kid from the other kid from modern
day uh bryce young is starting at
alabama
the kid from st john bosco
is starting at clemson
now whether these guys are you know
the best quarterbacks ever or nfl hall
of famers and all that isn't the point
the point is they all came from orange
county
and they left
like coach ozeron used to say
when things were rolling here
they would see other coaches show up at
lax
and they'd be like what are you doing
here
like other coaches from other schools
like why are you here are you on
vacation
like
what are you doing you're not getting
any of these kids get the hell out of
here you know like that was like the
running joke because you'd walk in with
the sc interlock to a high school
and everybody just lined up
i mean they were coach carroll was
recruiting guys just so they didn't go
to ucla
like it was crazy we had five five star
running backs at one point
it was like mark tyler manuel moody cj
gable stefan johnson
all in one running back room i was like
holy
this is unbelievable
how did that's the way it was how did
pete uh recruit you or ed
ooh coach oh
hey hey chess
you gonna hold the trophy you're gonna
hold the sword
in the rose bowl you're gonna be the
quarterback of the usc trojans
i was like he said you're going to stand
on the ladder and after that we're going
to i'm going to make you some gumbo
i said i don't know what gumbo is but
i'm in
i'll be there
and sure as heck man i i mean coach
carol literally sat in my living room
with my whole family
you know chewing gum like he does and
going a million miles an hour
and he was just such an energetic
personality they were putting out
quarterbacks left and right carson had
just gotten drafted liner was in the
running for he was just about to win the
heisman
and matt castle was getting drafted
after barely playing
i'm like this is a quarterback factory
sarkeesian is going to be there chow's
there odron's there where else would i
go
i mean it didn't make any sense to go
anywhere else you know i looked at ohio
state i looked at
texas i looked at notre dame and it was
like
why would i leave
there was you know there was no other
option and now once you see what link of
riley's done with all these other
quarterbacks
you're a quarterback here in orange
county
san diego la
northern california why would you leave
talking to mark sanchez the fox nfl
analyst he's got jags at the rams um
what concerns do you have with the rams
ooh
um you know it's it's interesting
because
when they lost robert woods and people
think like oh it's fine they just get
obj
well
woods plays z for them he's like their
flanker
and um
so now
van jefferson's kind of
in that role
and he's more of like
a slot and sometimes an x and not really
a z like he didn't really play robert's
position
so he's got to learn a lot
obj's got to learn a ton um you know i
watched their game last night from green
bay
uh last week just again before i go to
their practice tomorrow
and
um it's little stuff like when you go
system to system when you're you know
obj is on his third team and everybody's
like oh well why is he not panning out
why he's not good anymore was it baker
was it him well when you go from team to
team
these languages of offenses and the
little nuances
whether you take you know when you run a
two by two balance set and you run like
all slants give me give me another play
give me a complicated play
i mean it this isn't a complicated play
everybody runs it but you you know you'd
call it lion or dragon it's like drag
slant or line is all slant or triple
slant or whatever basically
some teams run them like five step
slants on the outside three step slants
on the inside some teams run them three
steps lands on the outside one step
slants on the inside
some teams run slants on the inside and
have like options where if you get
walled off by a backer or a nickel and
they don't let you go inside you just
slam on the brakes and pull back out of
the route
so everything's like a little different
everywhere you go driving a different
car dating a new girl some girls are
gluten free some girls eat anything you
know what i mean it's just different
same basic rules same game
but just a little different and you can
tell
they're trying to figure it out right
now and stafford's a little off with him
he's a little off with stafford
stafford's expecting him to run on a
certain route or slam on the brakes and
he's doing the opposite so they're still
feeling each other out and
it takes time but i mean the biggest
concern is
like if they don't rip off a bunch of
winds
they're gonna have to go back to green
bay yeah and it was freezing up there it
was like you know in the teens low teens
with the windchill
and they did not look good so
i mean that's my only fear with them
like they need to win a bunch of games
and green bay has to
hit a little slide if the rams want to
you know control home field and all that
what's worse for a quarterback snow rain
cold
wind uh
wind sucks
wins it like the old meadowlands yeah
the old giant stadium they would have to
keep so they had these two big garage
doors on each side
like on each end of the field kind of so
like emergency vehicles can come through
right
well
they'd have to keep one open as like
some sort of code or safety code or
whatever
so the wind would come in there and just
swirl
and you're like you literally have to
plan plays
based on the quarter like if you're
going to take a deep post shot
you can't throw it
into the win i mean at least i could and
maybe josh allen could maybe you know
maybe a handful of guys that have ever
played could have done it
but that was tough and it's like hey
we're going to hit this we're going to
try and hit flutie the deep post on it
um
we're going to have to try and get to it
in the second quarter because we're
going the wrong way right now
like it was ridiculous
so the wind totally sucks rains i mean
rain's never been that much of a problem
for me but i got really big hands
so i remember playing that that monday
night game against the vikings
against favre
and it was just pouring i mean just
absolutely drenched in warm-ups and
it was uh those weren't bad uh but i
mean just getting used to the cold like
i remember
you know i'm a socal kid man i grew up
in orange county i'm at the beach like
rainbow sandals all the time and then
you go to new york i mean i never played
a game in less than you know 52 degrees
so
it was
i mean we'd go out on tuesdays
and the equipment staff would wet the
balls down when it started to get cold
and just i'd have to go play catch and
just get used to it it sucked
my hands would hurt so bad and it was
just different so
you know it's different when you when
you drop the kids from the west coast
have you looked into the nft
with the uh the butt fumble to make some
money off of that to own that
you know that's funny my my best friend
actually talked about that because he's
like you know all these people are doing
it and making money i mean i i get how
like
the concept of it but it just seems so
weird
like i don't
that whole thing the bitcoin thing like
i just
i don't know that's really hard for me
to wrap my brain around that's just like
different and i know i don't know enough
about it to like jump in that arena so
i just kind of stayed away from it well
you should have skipped dance class
taking an econ class yeah something like
that i don't get the bitcoin a bitcoin
one either and even the nft i'm not
quite sure yeah
but the whole blockchain thing and we're
going to go mine this stuff and i'm like
what
what's it like living in the matrix
i remember the first time i walked on
usc's campus and i thought it was a
movie set
and uh
i still film a lot of movies there yeah
but i'm with my my son
who eventually went there and then my
one of my daughters but
you walk on that campus and you go this
isn't real it it's like
right
it's even nicer now have you seen it
recently oh yeah they built that village
anything recently in the last yeah oh
wait there's like a whole foods in the
trader joe's across the street that
market we used to go to that 3-2 market
had straight-up rats in there all the
time
all the time and i'm like getting eggs
like oh damn that's nasty yeah it's it's
a little different place was terrible
and then the movie theater oh my god
that movie theater there was
like homeless people in there the dudes
like we'd go see like saws were coming
that those saw movies were coming out so
everybody want to go see that
and i mean dudes are just like screaming
and they're like no don't go in the room
don't go in the room homeless guys in
there people like giving birth in there
it was disgusting i hated that place
dude i'm telling you that place was so
bad
it was so bad the fact that coach carol
got all those kids to go there with
those facilities and like the way the
campus was at the time that's crazy
that's crazy it i mean it didn't even
match up to anything that it is now or
any of the other schools i know
uh
tough life though tough life being a usc
student right so happy i went there i
mean
it's the best it's the best especially
if you're going to live here when you're
done
like if you're going to be in socal yeah
you went to usc
that's awesome man did you have a
football club
football class
yeah but was there one that all the
football players took aside from
ballroom dancing
oh oh um there was like a self-defense
class
that was kind of cool
well that might come in handy if you
went into the movie theater yeah exactly
that movie theater you needed it bro
that place was so bad self-defense no we
took like it was like karate or like
self-defense that one was pretty fun
um occupational therapy was a cool one
but a lot of guys were you know matt
said it yesterday a lot of guys were
sociology majors because nobody knew
what they wanted to do
everybody's just like okay i'll just go
soch and that's what they did
i ended up taking communication i
actually took a
a class on uh
on like fashion communication so like
the the gal uh paige from paige premium
denim which was super popular at the
time
came in and spoke to the class
i took a class with dr boyd and i think
like guillermo del toro came in
and spoke to us people from the office
jim and pam from the office came in when
the office was dead and they spoke to
our class it was awesome you get to see
like all the sneak peek movies and tv
shows that are out it was it was really
cool it was great yeah man
living the life good classes yeah
uh hey have fun with the jags and the
rams always great to catch up with you
uh my best to the family and uh thanks
again i appreciate that all right yes
sir that's uh mark sanchez fox nfl
analyst and uh former usc quarterback